where are these characters coming from
ah that's a good question that
everywhere I mean I I I don't know that
I specifically know any of the
characters in my scripts that exist in
the real world I would say they're
pieces of people that I know or pieces
of people that I want to know you know I
I in killing Winston Jones aly michalka
plays a stripper with stage fright you
know I don't know any women who are
exotic dancers that have stage fright or
performance anxiety but it was just
something that I thought was interesting
you know John heaters character plays a
mad scientist of sorts who loses his
favorite marmot in a seventh grade
science fair experiment and decides he's
going to debt it dedicate his life to
cryogenic so that he can bring this
Marmot back to life I don't know anyone
who's deeply into cryogenics or in the
science field but it's just something
that came out of me so I think that it
really just depends on the project and I
think you find those characters and
their voices along the way and I think
you start with the general idea you
start with the protagonist you start
with an antagonist and some of those be
stories whether it's the love story or
some some of those subsidiaries stories
those just start to evolve and those
characters start to gain traction gain
storylines gain arcs gain voices and I
think it writers probably surprised
themselves pretty often with the
different types of people that can
actually you know characters they can
create and come up with
you